[Music]
30 seconds to on
air okay and you are just here could I
said father
back now an extraordinary story about a
young man who many years ago visited
Prague what he found there with
thousands of refugees at the mercy of
Hitler's imminent
invasion
do you ever think about the children and
what happened to
them how about you got some
stories that's really not about
me we are working to evacuate these
children by train to Safety in Britain
why are you doing this Mr Winton because
I may be able to do something about it I
must go now
Nikki you must know we cannot save them
all you have to forgive yourself
that I'm started sir I have to finish
it we cannot let these people
down it is incredible what you
achieved we're doing as much as we
can you have a lot of faith in ordinary
people
because I'm an ordinary
person save one life save the world
forgive me but how many children are we
speaking
about can I ask is there anyone in the
audience tonight who owes their life to
Nicholas
[Music]
Winton